The proliferation of mobile devices has
revolutionized a number of industries,
and education is no different.
One of the real big strengths in
mobile devices is their ubiquity.
Most of our students already have
these kinds of mobile devices
in their pocket right now,
with them at all times.
And that gives us a real opportunity
to create some really interesting
learning activities.
So, for example,
if a student's at a national park or
a Civil War battlefield, they can have
their mobile device guide them around
the battlefield telling them different
things that happened at different times,
complete with animation and voice-overs.
So there's real opportunities to create
some really interesting learning
experiences.
As a new father, I'm very grateful for
the use of this technology in this way,
because my daughter gets a phone
call from Elmo every day, and
it just makes her face light
up whenever it happens.
So I'm very appreciative of
the possibility to use educational
technology in cahoots
with mobile devices.
But there are other things
to mobile devices as well.
There are different
features that they have.
They're different than anything
we've dealt with in the past.
They have a GPS.
They have a camera.
They have motion sensors.
And all of these things can be used
to create some really interesting
educational experiences and
different domains.
So what we're going to talk about
in this class is a lot about how
the ubiquity of mobile devices can be
leveraged to create unique experiences,
but also about how some of those
other features can be used in
other context as well.